ausgedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe heute selina
dabei sei clean afrika habe eben im auto
so gesagt da sollte ich anrufen da hat
er gesagt dass er muss ich mal sagen
irgendwie gélinas klima oder so ganz
transparent eingespeichert zu jener zeit
clean
wenn wir so wie soll ich nicht nach
namen kann man auch das team auf jeden
fall haben wir uns hier heute
zusammengefunden um ein video zu drehen
ach ja wie hier schon sehen und zwar
machen wir
wir waren dort einkaufen und haben
gegenseitig produkte gekauft wie man
sozusagen als kind nie martin wittwer
jetzt immer nicht also das versuchen wir
jetzt herausgestellt oder weil das kann
ja sein dass ich die geschmacksknospen
verändert haben und ich mache das jetzt
mag ja kann sein deswegen aber ich weiß
es nicht ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt an weil serena ist auch ein video
anderen gekommen wahrscheinlich dann
gerade oder schon irgendwie so hat
wahrlich in der beschreibung und las
immer abwechseln machen das heißt soll
ich empfinde zusammengestellt ich habe
hier eigentlich nur gute sachen also ich
kann mich dafür nur an das von dem
ebenfalls okay
als erstes haben wir hier ja das sind
cocktail connection ja einfach kleine
gewürzgurken das hört sich so braucht
wenn mich jetzt jemand fragen würde
magst du eigentlich cocktail koalition
klar wenn ich dann selber das ist ja
also das ist haben wir mehr gekauft ich
hasse gut und wirklich lebendig model in
meinem leben noch nie gurken ich hab'
ich hatte ein sehr sehr guter freund
meiner besten freunde wer hat früher in
der schule waren gurken mitgebracht und
so richtig fett begossen gegessen
michael hopf und tomatenmark so oft
nicht mehr das licht sorgt geil o mein
gott ich liebe es also ich früher so mit
youtube angefangen habe das ist schon
ewig mit meinen freunden aber es hat mir
so ein kanal
da wusste ich einfach als bestrafung
wurden wasser trinken und ich frei habe
das im ganzen auch noch ein bisschen bei
gefangen aber wir probieren jetzt
vielleicht ich finde es nicht richtig
lecker durch so diese dinge wirklich ich
finde dass sie diesen eigentlich
aussehen
wir sehen aussehen wir sehen aus wie so
eine verdorbene bikers mini saison recht
gut
das ist absolut musiksommer ist dass man
immer auch das muss man mal okay dann
richtung gerade nachgespielt jetzt hab
ich versprochen jetzt muss ich das ja
auch machen
das ist ja auch falls ich mich ja ja das
kann aber alles oder rauchen also ich
lasse ich jetzt mal den cocktail
connections ist maximal 1 und du kannst
jetzt sehr gerne wieder zudem schwer
hier ist mit nach hause
ja du kriegst ohne zu schenken wir waren
jetzt weiter und zwar bis zuletzt dran
wir haben gekauft zu lean hat mir
verraten sie hasst marzipan und da habe
ich hier die marzipankartoffeln gekauft
ja neun stück ich kann mich daran
erinnern ich habe damals auf maximal
gras aber mein papa der hat immer zu
weihnachten von mama so marzipan und
kriegt und irgendwann habe ich geliebt
seitdem es ich sehr sehr gerne marzipan
aber so pur wie das jetzt zum beispiel
ich es so geringer wo wir sein kann
schon fast krankhaft nein wir schauen
jetzt mal wieder auf die
marzipankartoffeln sogar zwölf trägt
sich diese kultur braucht man eine art
kann ich nicht raus torten oder so da
ist manchmal machen kann schlecht drauf
und ich bin dieser art von mensch die
das ab macht bevor sie den kuchen ist
sieht man auch so im abspann schlichtung
ja das kann ich auch verstehen wie lange
ist das her dass du das letzte mal war
zuvor gegessen hast also so eine richtig
so etwas richtig ist schon sehr lang
vielleicht hat sich nichts geändert wir
weithin greift nochmals zu greift immer
noch nicht reif dass ich nicht lust
kannst wirklich auch zwei gleichzeitig
nehmen wieder die so in der hand aufs
neue wie das so auseinander
ich muss mein gott du kannst du das
zirkus du musst alles essen jetzt hat
die meisten kartoffeln wollen die aus
klinischer proben sehr sehr lecker ist
einfach falsch also von der kunde stellt
sich ja das ist gar nicht so krass
programms preis geht auf filmen glaube
ich mal irgendwie zu unterrichten
ja ja ich weiß was du meinst also spd
gerade das ist ich sag mal so das
smartphone für anfänger
wenn ich auf das video marzipan für an
können was uns gut geschlagen also wir
haben natürlich auch socken gekauft die
wir beide nicht mögen und zwar kommt es
als nächstes da haben wir uns darauf
geeinigt das kriegen wir beide nicht ich
hasse so was und ich wusste auch nicht
dass es existiert aber ich find's super
eklig pfefferminz schokolade also
dritter sport schokolade mit pfefferminz
drin also diese after eight oder wieso
ritter sport mit berliner luft gefüllt
oder ja genau ja doch schon oder ich
finde die kombination schokolade einfach
komplett ja das ist
wenn ich das vielleicht tue ich mich da
jetzt auch und magst dann doch aber ich
weiß nicht wo wir sagen hier das ist
zwar nicht viel ein paar das passt
wirklich also mehr oder weniger sachen
einen tick weniger zusammen passen dass
das passt überhaupt nicht zu trauen
musik brauchen und das ist nicht so
cremiger fünf hört das ist wirklich
privat wetter so wasser drin was ich
wolle müsse es eine ganze tafel ist
erhält ihr parlaments bonbon vision
halle essen wie ein kaugummi und
schokolade dazu ich finde jetzt könnten
wir mal ein bisschen was trinken
er ist der motor stehen aber das ist ja
nur für mich ja du machst es ja nein
weiß ich nicht ach so wahrscheinlich ist
das ist auch eine sache die viele nicht
irgendwer
weil ich weiß dass ich das als kind
aufgepasst hat und manchmal wird man das
glaube ich auch im flugzeug angeboten
wobei daher meistens tomatensaft angebot
wird aber auch karotten sagt kannst du
aufnehmen zumindest wegen das früher
und ja ich finde es absolut schrecklich
und allein schon wenn ich daran denke
karotten flüssig zu trinken oder
deswegen war ich nur mal eben einen
platz habe ich immer das ohr anmeldung
ist widerlich
und dann auf diese scheiße hier müssen
es ist nicht sauer figuren milchbauer
figuren geschmückt bitte schreibt meine
kommentare wenn ihr das möchte das noch
nach oben da und wir nicht andersrum ich
glaube ich erst wenn ihr mögt der lassen
doch um das nicht mögt dann lassen da
absolut nicht dass jona karotten oder
hatte schon so ein bisschen nach vortrag
und ab das uns erst mal einen kleinen
schluck nehmen um dann zu merken wie
scheiß es scheint also ich finde das
schmeckt nicht intensiv nach karotten
schmeckt so wässrig absolut wieder nicht
kann das meeting irgendwo durch also ich
muss auch sagen ich hab selber etwas
ekliges getrunken aber es wird es war
noch schlimmer wenn der karottensaft
intensiver und dieser fläche ziehen
damit wir uns immer daran interessiert
wenn ich entwickle ich gedacht das
eigentlich ganz bestimmt nicht sagen du
bist jetzt mal an und zwar habe ich
erfahren sie wie nachbars lakritz das
machte sie noch nie und deswegen haben
wir hier natürlich die großen sachen
gekauft
ich würde eigentlich bereiche wie das
jetzt mal vor
das habe ich früher auf dem schulhof
gelernt wie man das macht und vielleicht
damit nur noch ein bisschen mehr
brokdorf ist wir hatten auch immer so
mädels in der klasse oder schule
wir haben das dann so ausgeräumt und
kennst du die leute die das dann so so
richtig den rachen grundhaft runter
wieso wieder rausgezogen natürlich geht
das nicht machen weil du musst ja schon
die ganze runde ist ja
haben wir haben das ding es gibt glaube
ich weise sie hassen dass wir den lieben
das rechtsextremistische leder mit dem
hund richtig lederer gesagt wo man mal
sagen ich habe jetzt auch ziemlich viel
gleichzeitig auch nicht so recht aber
das gilt ja auch so gummibärchen
die haben da so häfele krebs hälfte
nochmal sie sind wieder sehr lecker
nicht rein werden wir das jetzt in ruhe
auf ist kannst du ja schon mal nicht
aufs nächste konzentrieren hat mir das
schon mal leben oder auch dass leute das
betrifft jetzt eigentlich wieder nur
mich glaube ich der mit abstand ekligste
schokoriegel der existiert also ich weiß
nicht wie man das mögen kann ich will
jetzt hier kein angreifen oder so aber
das ist wirklich schlecht gebaute magst
du auch nicht also nicht so gerne
also den hund bounty meine ich nicht
hast du dir ist okay das ist jetzt mal
schnell ja klar
kokosnuss deswegen das hat schlimmer das
ist mir zu sehr
also das schmeckt irgendwie komisch und
es passt auch wieder die genau ist
passiert und ich lass uns den ganzen
reinschieben
also ich bin damals noch nur so dass es
auf der zunge zergeht bis jetzt mit zwei
schokolade ist es so langsam geplant
von den grünen das war nicht das was ich
immer gedacht so feste stücke zum teil
noch drin sind und manche frauen kann du
kaufst du und du hängst aber das
irgendwie sowieso voll aber schmeckt
intensiv nach kokos du hast dich
empfinde ich jetzt gerade auf dauer so
viel drin dass ich keine andere collage
und kokos drin ist eine kleine schicht
ist das nicht viel intensiver ja und
jetzt sogar noch diese stücke über das
ist nämlich das wichtigste das ansonsten
schon wieder ist dass die beine nicht
mögen und die ach du machst das auch
nicht
ach so ich dachte ich hätte
aufrichtigkeit aktie aber denken das
video und das war richtig schlecht ich
dachte möglichst das ok also ich hab ich
wirklich sehr leid wenn ich jetzt das
ist wieder so ekelhaft stell dir vor du
müsstest zum frühstück oliven mit cover
und zu guten essen alter da würde ich ja
weg
dann würde ich sagen ladies first formal
zu suchen wir eine aus du kannst du auch
so gut raus und mit deinen langen
fingernägeln boote haben so viele karten
ist kannst du besser sehen es ist gut
für die augen wird nicht besser und sagt
einfach nur muss die haut nenne das ist
fällt du hast man menschen gesehen der
ganze druck und studiert und hast du
hast wirklich so viele geworden so hier
aber genauso wie die gurken dass das
schlimmste films sind aber ich muss
sagen es kann nicht verstehen wie du die
kurve so lecker finden kannst dich und
isolieren
also meiner meinung das ist ja auch
einmal das schmeckt auch noch sein die
konsistenz ist eben nicht nur das
aussehen des anwalts
heute sind sie eigentlich auch schon am
ende
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen dass wir
genau nach oben hat checkt das video von
celina bis in der video entscheidung
ganz oben verlinkt das macht man doch
was machen wir denn jetzt noch gar nicht
beim video mir wir haben licht und
drehen gleich weitere cellino bis jetzt
kann ich nur weil das gehalt des lichts
man sich nicht mit dir war einer der
chili ja das könnte dann willst du
kannst kein scharfes essen
doch klar wurde nein kann hier
eigentlich habe ich will eigentlich
nicht so gut dass also ich kann das
schon aber ich werde endlich fangen
schnell an zu schützen also das ist mein
ding und wollen aber gar kein problem
das kriegen wir schon hin dann
beantworten wir halt alle fragen richtig
deswegen zeigt das video ab aber wir den
kanal und wir sind uns im laufe der
woche wieder rein